après sept ans de rénovation intensive
l'édifice de l'ouest est presque prêt à
rouvrir ses portes
pendant qu'on apporte la touche finale
c'est toute nouvelle chambre des
communes qui reste temporaire
son concepteur a bien hâte d'en faire
découvrir l'espace construit dans la
cour intérieure où 338 il eu je pense
que n'importe quelle heure architecte
vous désirez c'est qu'on cherche
toujours à voir ce que les occupants ce
que les députés dans ce cas ici vont
nous dire plafond envers poutres d'acier
et pierre de grains rien dans ce mariage
de matériaux neufs historique n'a été
laissé au hasard
anciennement on était ouvert à
l'extérieur au ciel puis on se
retrouvait avec une verdure à
l'intérieur donc on se retrouve avec des
arbres moderne qui monte avec des
branches en porte-à-faux qui tient le
ciel est notre la faune vitré pendant au
moins une décennie
l'édifice de l'ouest abritera aussi les
bureaux du premier ministre du chef de
l'opposition et des agents du parlement
notamment à quelques coins de rue
l'ouverture du sénat temporaire dans
l'ancien centre de conférences du
gouvernement marque aussi un tournant
dans un effort de modernisation les
débats à la chambre haute
seront captées par des caméras pour la
toute première fois
une nouveauté qui pourrait modifier le
comportement de certains sénateurs les
citoyens d'abord vont constater que le
temps des débats au sénat
et quand même un ton généralement
sérieux mais il reste encore des relents
d'une certaine partisanerie des gens qui
ont beaucoup en tête
langer électoralement et je pense que ça
devrait changer
rarement les bâtiments du sénat et de la
chambre des communes font plus parler
d'eux que les parlementaires qui y
siègent moment pour les canadiens
d'évaluer le rôle du parlement selon le
premier ministre
je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
qu'on est en train de réfléchir à nos
institutions à l'étape de démocratie
comment on va continuer de s'y engager
de façon digne d'heure de notre histoire
ces chambres ont beau être temporaires
elles seront utilisées pendant une
décennie au moins
il bon nombre des parlementaires qui
siégeront pourrait y terminer leur
carrière ici mathieu gaye et radio
canada ottawa